de la chaîne d'information politique
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre dans un instant un débat
sur la crise du lait en présence de
bruno le maire le nouveau ministre de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche le lait c'est un dossier brûlant
qu'il récupère il faut dire que les
producteurs de lait sont confrontés
depuis des mois une chute brutale des
prix en raison d'une surproduction au
niveau mondial un peu partout en france
ils mènent des actions de protestations
sur le terrain pour réclamer un
relèvement des prix il exige également
que bruxelles revienne sur sa décision
de supprimer progressivement les quotas
laitiers
déjà à la fnsea le principal syndicat
agricole a déclaré que bruno le maire ne
bénéficierez owni d'un temps mort ni
d'un état de grâce pour régler au plus
vite ces dossiers brûlants
voilà pour les enjeux du débat de ce
matin bonne matinée à tous sur public
sénat l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
sur la crise de la filière laitière
la parole est un notre collègue gérard
bailly au nom du groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire auteur de la demande
d'inscription à l'ordre du jour en chers
collègues vous avez la parole
mais c'est le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
d'abord vous permettrez monsieur le
ministre vous adresser mes plus sincères
félicitations pour votre mine est votre
nomination à ce grand ministère de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche
je me réjouis parlement alimentation qui
figure maintenant dans vos
responsabilités parce que n'est ce pas
le mot le plus majeur et noble de
justement de notre paysannerie quand
même qui fait l'alimentation de notre
pays
je trouve très opportun que nous
évoquions plus précisément la crise
laitière après ce débat que nous venons
d'avoir sur le volet agricole de la
négociation de l'om c'est pour évoquer
plus particulièrement maintenant la
situation de notre filière laitière
surtout qu'elle est préoccupante comme
cela que j'étais il ya quelques instants
elle est grave aujourd'hui la colère des
producteurs est réel et inquiétante
après les douze mille producteurs qui
ont manifesté à travers toute la france
le 25 mai dernier bloquant certaines
lectrices usines et supermarchés le
mouvement s'est radicalisé le week-end
des 13 et 14 juin des manifestations
importantes ont eu lieu ces derniers
jours à bruxelles et à luxembourg
le blocage d'une quarantaine de
plateformes d'approvisionnement de la
grande distribution pendant 48 heures
par sept mille d'entre eux ait des
débordements au sein de certaines
grandes surfaces naturellement nous
inquiète
la tension monte aide à tournus on ne
peut prendre que peut prendre les mêmes
des événements et imprévisible si aucune
solution n'est rapidement trouvée je ne
souhaite pas que dans les prochaines
semaines ce dossier passe des mains de
votre ministère menace ennemie ni de
l'agriculture à celle du ministre de
l'intérieur par rapport à la sécurité et
pour cause nous revenons tout d'abord
mais revenons tout d'abord à l'origine
de cette crise la baisse soudaine et
brutale du prix du lait celui ci qui
avait connu une flambée entre
2006 2008 après n'avoir cessé je
rappelle de baisser entre 2001 et 2006
est retombé à un niveau historiquement
bas
sinon ça rapporte au graphique retraçant
les prix à la production en moyenne
annuelle depuis dix ans on se rend
compte qu'il était de 31 centimes
d'euros par litre en 2001 puis je l'a
progressivement tombé à 26 07 en 2006
avant de remonter à 33,6 l'année
dernière mais mais depuis le prix payé
au producteur a brutalement tombé vous
le savez 21 22 23 centimes ce dépend
aussi des régions et aussi les
productions soit un niveau très
inférieur
on le sait maintenant presque tous au
coût de production les producteurs ont
ainsi dû accepter une baisse des prix de
près de 30% à la dernière livraison en
avril est surtout qu'elle était décidée
unilatéralement par les entreprises de
transformation assurant la collecte de
leur lait or cette baisse est d'autant
plus choquante qu'elle ne s'accompagne
pas d'une baisse similaire des prix de
vente des produits laitiers aux
consommateurs au premier trimestre s'ils
n'ont reculé que d'environ 2 2%
alors comment expliquer cet écart non
par une baisse brutale de la
consommation de ces produits qui sonna
qui stagne ou qui ne décroît que très
légèrement sur le long terme
j'ai pu constater moi-même ces primes et
je vous invite chers collègues à vous
rendre dans les gms en province mais ici
comme à paris j'ai vu des prix 0,84 0,89
0,99 pour les rentiers 0,80 0,70 pour
les demi écrémé et enfin en cherchant
bien dans les rayons après aux six
mètres enseigner près des vendeurs j'ai
pu trouver moi dans la supermarché dans
mon département qu'il convient il
au meilleur prix est bien près des
rayons de l'eau minérale donc tout à
l'opposé des produits laitiers des
briques de lait demi écrémé qui étaient
là 0,59
mais je peux vous dire que c'est un
véritable jeu de piste pour les trouver
parce que c'est vrai qu'on nous dit on
sait ce prix là mais je crois que c'est
vraiment pas bien à la vue des
consommateurs
nous voudrions tous que les gms nous
explique qu'elle
leur charge qui nécessite une telle plus
value je m'adresse aussi aux
transformateurs pour qu'enfin cesse
cette opacité des méthodes que personne
n'ose évoquer de peur d'être déréférencé
la filière laitière représente un
véritable poids économique nous le
savons tous et social il ressemble et
rassemble ainsi 95 mille producteurs il
y en avait 100 51000 en 1988 700000
entreprise privée coopérative et près de
200000 emplois au total son chiffre
d'affaires était de 23 à milly 7,23
milliards d'euros en 2007 et générer un
excédent commercial de 2,9 milliards
d'euros
mais n'oublions pas surtout en plus dans
l'importance économique de l'emploi
le rôle des éleveurs pour notre
environnement et l'aménagement de nos
territoires dans les zones d'herbage à
l'herbe la friche rendrait vite leur
plein le relais de nos verts pâturages
si nous n'y prenons garde mais je vais
vous citer chers collègues de chiffres
pour vous dire quand même que le nombre
de vaches laitières a beaucoup baissé
puisque en 1983 il y en avait sept
millions 166 mille et aujourd'hui c'est
3 millions 800 mille plus de diminution
de plus de 3 millions de vaches
laitières et cela aussi ça joue comme
dans le rapport que nous avions fait
avec françois fortassin sur l'élevage
ovin aussi de passer de 11 à 8 millions
8 millions de de 20 dans notre sur notre
territoire
voyez la diminution du nombre le dirait
d'herbivores comme elle a diminué depuis
ces vingt dernières années
et bien entendu cela nous et qui nous
inquiète pour notre environnement
alors je me félicite bien sûr et comment
se félicite nombreux ici dans cette
assemblée que les dernières réformes de
la pac revenir des primes sur l'herbe
pour inciter bien entendu aider ces
éleveurs dans souvent dans des zones de
montagne dans des zones difficiles
je crois que l'on peut s'en féliciter
mais je crois que ce sera
malheureusement expliqué qu'en 2010 et
que c'est vrai que d'ici là espérons que
pas trop d'entre eux se décourageront
tu pourras non plus qu'on n'oublie pas
le rôle stratégique dans notre filière
laitière française tant elle contribue à
la préservation de l'indépendance
alimentaire de notre pays cela a été
rappelé dans le débat ya quelques
instants
qu'adviendrait-il si nous ne maîtrisions
plus l'approvisionnement de notre pays
comment garantir la qualité et la
sécurité sanitaire de produits provenant
d'autres pays qui n'ont pas forcément
les exigences aussi strict que nous
avons sur ces critères et puis je ne
crois pas non plus que c'est ce qui est
souhaité dans lé grenelle de
l'environnement vous le savez la
production de lait obéit à des
contraintes très particulière il s'agit
d'un produit lourdes volumineuses
fragiles ne pouvant pas être stockée
longuement le métier particulièrement
difficile avec deux traites quotidiennes
et peu de temps libre pour la vie privée
on remarque ceux qui ont cessé d'être
producteur producteurs laitiers ne
reviennent jamais les investissements
sont très lourds en dans l'installation
des liquettes et ne sont rentabilisés
qu'au bout de nombreuses années enfin
les producteurs ne connaissent le prix
qui leur sera payé qu'un mois et demi
après l'avoir livré le relais il faut
bien avoir ces considérations à l'esprit
lorsque nous parlons de l'est il ne
s'agit pas d'un bien industriel commun
d'autres mais d'un produit vivant
étroitement lié à l'animal et à l'homme
qu'ils ont produit ces dernières années
les prix du lait faisait l'objet d'une
recommandation nationale trimestriel de
l'interprofession le centre national
interprofessionnel de l'économie
laitière le cnj elle basée sur la
combinaison de différents indicateurs et
à caractère non obligatoire les criel
enquêtes qui sont leurs structures
régionales du miel était les enceintes
de discussions au niveau local entre
producteurs et transformateurs ou sur la
base de la recommandation nationale
étaient discutés les prix de base de se
brûler à ce titre la filière laitière
était souvent cité en exemple pour son
organisation mais aussi son sens de
responsabilité
or vous le savez une lettre de la
direction générale de la consommation et
de la concurrence de la répression des
fraudes dgccrf demande à
l'interprofession laitière de cesser ses
recommandations en matière d'évolution
de prix à
été adressées au mois d'avril 2008 au
président du cnj l ailier assimile l
accord interprofessionnel sur le prix du
lait à une entente interdites par la
réglementation communautaire dont un
secteur comme la viande bovine vous le
savez avait déjà fait les frais en
france lorsqu'il y avait eu comme on dit
la crise de la vache folle conformément
à la jonction de la dg srf l'athlète
niel a immédiatement cessé d'émettre ses
recommandations dès le 1er juillet 2000
alors depuis cette remise en cause du
cadre interprofessionnel
le système a volé en éclats et des
acteurs ne s'entendent plus en effet les
transformateurs et les distributeurs
n'ont pas joué le jeu en ont profité
pour ne pas venir à la table des
négociations soit neutre présentant
aucun chiffre soit en proposant des prix
d'achat du lait du lait comme vous le
savez est manifestement trop faible le
gouvernement et plus particulièrement
votre prédécesseur michel barnier qui je
rends hommage n'est cependant pas resté
inactif à court terme deux médiateurs
ont été nommés pour encourager la
reprise des négociations entre les
parties prenantes au niveau national et
régional dans les compétences ont été
salués celles ci ont pu aboutir un
accord conclu sur le prix du lait le 3
juin qui réévaluent légèrement à la
hausse le prix du lait pour les
prochaines livraisons
s'il ne règle pas les problèmes sur le
long terme cet accord a le mérite
d'exister est de permettre à la filière
de sortir de l'ornière dans l'urgence à
moyen terme il est prévu que le projet
de loi de modernisation de l'agriculture
attendue d'ici la fin de l'année offre
de nouveaux outils permettant
d'améliorer la transparence et de mieux
organiser la filière le sud ministre
pouvez-vous je sais que votre nomination
est toute récente
mais pourrait vous peut-être déjà nous
dira un petit peu plus sur ce sujet là
et puis qu'est-ce que nous pourrons
ensemble je crois préparer pour une
meilleure organisation de ce secteur
agricole mais secteur laitier en
particulier nous le savons aussi votre
prédécesseur a obtenu dans le cadre du
bilan de santé de la pac société dit
tout à l'heure obtenu de rendez vous à
mi pente
cours sur leur marché laitier en 2010 et
en 2012 qui n'étaient pas prévus au
calendrier européen à l'idée d'un
maintien du système des quotas après
2013 ne peut-être pas complètement
écartée au vu de la conjoncture
européenne et mondiale de cette
production
les instances européennes que vous
connaissez bien monsieur mini ce seront
peut-être vous écouter vous n'avez dit à
quelques instants la crise du lait a été
mise sur l'initiative elle sur
l'initiative française à l'ordre du jour
du conseil des ministres européens de
l'agriculture du 25 mai dernier et
quelques mesures de soutien ont été
annoncés prolongement de l'intervention
et des aides au stockage privé du beurre
paiement anticipé à 70% des des
subventions des producteurs laitiers
pour 2010 les plus touchées dès octobre
prochain
mais la commission a rejeté toute remise
en cause de la hausse progressive des
quotas d'ici 2013 puis de leur
suppression pour commissaire européen
madame mariette gerber
ce ne sont pas les hausses de quotas qui
explique la crise actuelle mais la
surproduction mondiale et la baisse de
consommation
permettez-moi de target interrogatif sur
cette prestation
pensez vous monsieur le ministre que nos
partenaires européens puissent évoluer
sur ce sujet et que cette décision qui a
été prise dans un contexte aujourd'hui
cadic puisse bien sûr être révisé je
voudrais maintenant on vous dira que
notre commission justement à travailler
par l'intermédiaire notre commission des
affaires économiques à travailler plus
particulièrement par le groupe d'étude
d'élevage que j'anime et qui a mis en
place un mini groupe qui est pour suivre
ce dossier
c'est pourquoi nous avons fait un
certain nombre d'auditions nous avons
reçu bien sûr à leur demande déjà il ya
quelques presque mois maintenant les
jeunes agriculteurs très inquiets nous
avons reçu monsieur jérôme bédier le
président de la fédération du commerce
et de la distribution
d'abord entendu nous avons entendu les
entreprises entremont et danone
avons entendu la fédération nationale
des producteurs de lait fnpl
et hier matin nos ans nous avions en
audition le cnj elle nous avons
également reçu au sein de la mission des
affaires économiques
spansion président la semaine dernière
monsieur luc chatel et nous poursuivrons
nos auditions dans les semaines à venir
et jusqu'à la rentrée puisque nous
devrions encore recevoir la dgccrf
l'observatoire des prix et des marges
les médiateurs qui ont été nommés par le
gouvernement et le président de
l'autorité de la concurrence
il me semble que nous pouvons tous nous
accorder aujourd'hui pour dire qu'elle
est nécessaire non pas que le prix des
produits les dialogues ans à la
consommation baissent par les
producteurs seraient les premiers encore
en pâtir mais que la répartition de la
valeur ajoutée tout au long de la
filière soit plus équilibré et plus
équitable est il normal et juste
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
un producteur qui a vendu son litre de
lait un peu plus de 20 centimes d'euro
le voile comme je l ai dit tout à
l'heure
commercialisée dans des grandes surfaces
proches de chez lui à 1 rôles dit sous
le sceau d'une grande marque nationale
je me répète mais il faut mettre fin à
l'opacité couvrant la formation de
suprises finale en introduisant plus de
transparence
l'observatoire des prix et des marges
créé par la loi de modernisation de
l'économie lme doit maintenant
travailler sur ce sujet à un niveau plus
opérationnel il faudra que producteurs
transformateurs et distributeurs se
retrouvent à nouveau à la même table et
discutent ouvertement de la répartition
des prix entre les différents maillons
de la filière
cela exige que ces deux derniers
transformateurs et distributeurs
prennent leurs responsabilités devant
l'opinion et les pouvoirs publics en
communiquant leurs chiffres et en
assumant les prix d'achat et de revente
ainsi que les marches qu'il pratique
monsieur bédié nous a dit qu'elle était
d'accord pour participer à
l'observatoire des marges mais à
condition nous l'at il dit ceci terme de
ne pas être sur un strapontin
or la réunion qui a eu lieu le 17 juin
au ministère de l'économie entre tous
les acteurs dette
r je crois a peu évolué d'une part
toutes les grandes ancien de la
distribution n'était pas directement
présente quand je pose la question
pourquoi
de plus ces positions n'ont guère
semblait prête à évaluer a évolué
paraissent irréconciliables même si tout
le monde a pu dire plus de sérénité au
sein de cette filière
c'est les gms ont si peu de marges
qu'elle le dise cela ne doit pas être si
difficile à prouver
dans un souci d'apaisement pourquoi ne
laisseraient pas leurs marges
pendant cette crise si aigu de quelques
centimes au delà des mesures que nous
pourrons prendre il reste indispensable
aux producteurs de mieux s'organiser en
amont afin de renforcer leur pouvoir de
négociation face aux transformateurs et
aux distributeurs
il faut également protéger des éleveurs
dans leurs relations commerciales avec
ces derniers au moyen d'une
contractualisation je le rappelle
équilibré nous savons tous les pressions
pesant sur les éleveurs depuis l'aval de
la filière et à cet égard la mise en
place dans chaque département des
brigades de contrôle me paraît une très
bonne initiative
elle devait est très utile aux
producteurs est elle devrait très utile
aux producteurs et aux pme qui hésite
toujours à dénoncer les pratiques
illégales de la commercialisation de
plus élaboration d'un cadre
interprofessionnel permettant la mise en
place d'une contractualisation à partir
de 2010 constitue l'un des trois points
issus de l'accord du 3 juin
il faut aller rapidement dans ce sens
par ailleurs nous n'écouterons nous
n'éviterons pas de revenir au niveau
européen sur le régime laitiers et de
rediscuter de la fin programmée des
quotas laitiers
cela a été dit les évolutions erratiques
des marchés agricoles montrent une fois
de plus qu'ils ne peuvent être
abandonnés au lucre jeu de la
concurrence mais qu'ils doivent faire
l'objet d'une régulation par les
pouvoirs publics
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre de
l'avoir évoqué quelques minutes et que
c'était pour vous une priorité vous le
savez les productions agricoles sont en
effet très largement soumise aux aléas
climatiques aux aléas sanitaires ou
économique
des mécanismes de stockage de dégagement
doivent être maintenus voire amplifier
ils reprennent d'ailleurs nous aurions
pas eu la crise l'an dernier
avec l'augmentation s'il importante du
prix du lait si bienvenue des stocks
à ce moment-là il représente une méthode
efficace pour lisser les prix comme
j'aime le dire en cas de sur ou de sous
production
ainsi on peut déplorer la politique
menée en la matière depuis plusieurs
années par l'europe et les etats-unis
ces derniers qui d'ailleurs viennent de
se rendre compte de cette situation en
commande et commence à qui viennent de
décider d'un vaste programme d'abattage
de vaches laitières
l'europe doit également soutenir les
mécanismes d'assurance récolte pour la
filière lait des possibilités ont été
ouvertes en ce sens dans le bilan de
santé de la pac
il faut que notre pays veille à les
concrétiser dans son droit national
des questions restent en suspens comment
discuter publiquement des marches sont
tombés de lampon condamné par la loi et
sans revenir au contrôle des prix
mais si jérôme baigner gelé dit prêt
dans la fcd a proposé d'instaurer une
sorte de prix directeur entre
producteurs et industriels
l'idée que le cnj elles établissent des
indices de prix permettent déclaré des
acteurs de la filière la négociation
relevant ensuite des relations
contractuelles entre producteurs et
transformateurs nous par une bonne chose
c'est pourquoi notre commission à
l'initiative de son président jean paul
emorine que je salue et que je remercie
a décidé comme lalem lui en donne la
possibilité de saisir l'autorité de la
concurrence d'un avis sur la question
les conclusions sont attendues pour la
rentrée parlementaire d'octobre et nous
nous ne manquerons pas alors d'avoir de
nouveau des échanges sur ce point autre
interrogation que l'on peut légitimement
se poser
pourrait-on interdire la vente de lait
en dessous de son coût de production de
la même façon que l'on interdit
aujourd'hui la revente à perte
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est bien le
cas pour de nombreux éleveurs qui ont vu
leur charge s'envoler sans pouvoir les
répercuter pourtant vous le savez c'est
l'énergie c'est la main de
c'est le matériel ceux des transports
c'est les engraisse les frais
vétérinaires c'est l'alimentation du
bétail
je vais terminer monsieur le président
c'est la aimé ça et tout ça qui au fond
monte beaucoup les chars dans les
exploitations voilà mes chers collègues
des quelques éléments et questionnements
que je souhaitais vous livrer pour
initier notre débat aujourd'hui nous
devons être déterminés à trouver des
solutions sur cette crise quitte à
légiférer
je l' ai déjà dit c'est les partenariats
de la filière ne tombe pas ensemble
d'accords il est important car le débat
de ce jour 2 montre à quel point notre
assemblée est concerné sur ce sujet il
nous faut maintenant apporter des
solutions qu'on traite concrètes et je
sais monsieur deux ministres après vous
avoir entendu il ya quelques minutes que
vous aurez à coeur d'y travailler avec
nous pour trouver des solutions
ce ne sera sans doute pas facile mais
votre connaissance des problèmes
européens
votre connaissance de l'allemagne
principal pays producteur de lait en
europe est pour nous une très bonne
chose
de même que votre connaissance de
l'importance des mécanismes de l' os x
est de loin celle évoquée il ya quelques
instants vous permettra une grande
efficacité dans votre nouvelle fonction
il nous faudra aussi être convaincant il
vous faudra aussi être convaincant au
sein du gouvernement français pour
permettre une bonne organisation des
filières agricoles plus particulièrement
les tiers donner un réel pouvoir aux
interprofessions et enfin nous attendons
très vite la réalisation de contrôles
des marges comme michel barnier et luc
chatel s'y sont engagés car le temps est
compté et puisque vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure je vous souhaite bon appétit et
que oui j'ai déjà convaincre madame le
commissaire européen
dans quelques instants merci de votre
attention
merci merci mon cher collègue dans la
suite du débat la parole et à jack krine
gros quand le groupe union centriste
je vous signale mes chers collègues que
je ne vous en voudrais absolument pas si
vous respectez votre temps de parole
ça me semble même est une initiative
heureuse madame la sénatrice vous avez
la parole monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues à mon
tour monsieur ministre permettez moi de
vous féliciter pour votre nomination à
ce poste de ministre de l'alimentation
et de l'agriculture je connais pas tout
la bombe voilà l appel j'ai oublié voilà
je n'oublie pas la pêche mais élu du
loir et cher je pense d'abord à
l'agriculture avant de passer à la
pratique
je suis obligé de le dire même si un
parlementaire doit avoir une vision
nationale monsieur le ministre
évidemment vous qui venez d'un
département aussi où l'agriculture est
importante je pense que vous comprendrez
avant que j'intervienne précisément sur
cette crise du lait que je pense que
l'agriculture est quelque chose de
fondamental dans notre économie
française
mais c'est aussi je dirais une vision de
la ruralité que nous partageons je crois
tout c'est à dire que nous n'imaginons
pas que là les lire la ruralité puisse
se faire sans les agriculteurs et ça je
crois que c'est très important de le
rappeler
et sans une agriculture je dirais
familiale à dimension humaine qui fasse
vivre les producteurs sur le territoire
et dans notre ruralité
alors pourquoi une telle crise en 2009
en fait on peut dire qu'elle n'aurait
pas été possible avant les réformes de
la pac de 2003 et 2006 en effet les
mécanismes de régulation aurait pas liés
les effets conjoncturels qui l'ont
déclenché et quels effets conjoncturels
et bien l'essentiel nous le savons c'est
la flambée des cours des matières
premières et les fonds spéculatifs
investissent massivement dans les
produits laitiers industriels et dans
les produits dans le blé deuxième point
les les sécheresses simultanée en
australie en océanie en nouvelle zélande
et puis troisième point bien sûr le
retournant brut retournement brutal des
marchés due à la crise financière
alors évidemment quelles auraient été
les mécanismes avant avant les réformes
de 2003 et 2006 eh bien ces mécanismes
aurait consisté à déclencher l'achat au
prix d'intervention à soutenir les
exportations permettant les dégagements
de marché poudrez beurre et enfin
organiser le marché grâce au recours aux
quotas or les réformes de la pac ont
consisté sur une base essentiellement
vous me permettrez ce mot idéologique a
augmenté les quotas ce qui revient
d'ailleurs à en supprimer les faits et
on espère que cette augmentation est
enfin en suppose que cette augmentation
pardon et on n'espère pas on suppose que
cette augmentation est un prélude à leur
suppression est évidemment à supprimer
le prix d'intervention et à supprimer
les restitutions aux exportations
résultat au plus fort d'une crise
conjoncturelle
l' équilibre fragile de toute une
filière conduit à une hécatombe
économique et social vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir les situations dramatiques
de nombreuses familles dont les
exploitations ne trouve pas de preneur
il y à des exploitations où il n'y a
plus de collecte de lait jeu jétais il
ya quinze jours un comice agricole dans
mon département à savigny sur braye
c'est dans le perche et
les agriculteurs et les producteurs
laitiers avaient tenu à amener leur
bétail à faire je dirai au fond la fête
agricole puisque les comices agricoles
sont des fêtes agricoles
ils ont tenu à être là ils ont tenu à
montrer leur volonté de se battre pour
sauver leur métier mais en même temps on
voyait leur très grande inquiétude et je
dirais le regard prouvait que certains
étaient désespérés devant la situation
est donc je crois qu'il faut prendre
conscience et vite prendre des décisions
avant que des drames humains ne se
développe dans les campagnes françaises
je disais idéologie tout à l'heure car
le système des quotas et de régulation
des marchés a permis à la filière
laitière de fonctionner pendant 20 ans
d'avoir le prix agricole le plus stable
de toute l'agriculture de renouveler
mieux que tout autre filière ses actifs
on a installé des jeunes agriculteurs
plus que dans tout rotos rivière dans la
filière laitière et puis bien sûr tout
en coûtant très peu au budget de l'union
européenne puisque c'était 2 à 3 % du
budget de la pac pour écouler de façon
marginale les stocks sous forme de
poudre et de beurre
alors pourquoi le scénario du pire est
encore aujourd'hui je dirais possible et
bien parce que la suppression des quotas
est une impasse
les rapports de force entre les acteurs
économiques production transformation
distribution sont telles que sans
mesures de contingentement de production
qui équilibre les négociations la
production est écrasé par les
possibilités pour les entreprises d'aval
de corriger les effets du marché pour
elle même c'est un phénomène en cascade
cette filière est à la merci de tout
retournement de tendance de marché il
n'y a aucun espoir pour les producteurs
de ville
de ce métier sans mécanismes de
régulation du prix à l'échelle
collective à l'échelle nationale ou par
grands bassins de collecte
monsieur le ministre je pense que la
responsabilité politique des décideurs
nationaux et communautaires est très
très importante
je crois qu'il ne sert à rien de faire
peser toute la responsabilité sur la
grande distribution et sur les
industriels il est urgent de partager la
responsabilité
il est urgent d'aménager le droit de la
concurrence de manière à permettre aux
producteurs de s'organiser pour
rééquilibrer le dialogue
interprofessionnel et les négociations
commerciales
j'espère monsieur le ministre que votre
nomination apportera une réelle solution
à la crise que vivent nos producteurs de
lait en france
je vous remercie merci enfin chers
collègues
la parole est à gérard le cam pour le
groupe crc spg
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
la crise laitière 2009 pressenti depuis
2008 fait partie du paysage désormais
habituel est cyclique des crises qui
frappent de façon quasi chronique les
productions agricoles alimentaires dans
leur ensemble chaque crise apporte son
lot de colère d'exaspération de
renoncement et de faillite des
producteurs qui constitue pourtant la
trame de notre ruralité
chaque crise mène à un degré de
concentration plus élevée des
exploitations au bénéfice d'une
rentabilité accrue pour les
transformateurs et la grande
distribution
ainsi le nom de l'ach métier a reculé de
14 2% comme la période 2001-2007 et plus
de 28 mille exploitations ont disparu
avec une augmentation de population de
plus de 10 millions d'habitants depuis
1985 la collecte annuelle de l'est a par
contre reculé de 25 milliards de litres
de lait à 23 milliards de litres soit
deux milliards en moins les causes des
crises laitières sont multiples et bien
identifié les crise laitière elle-même
affaiblissent la production
les producteurs le pouvoir d'achat en
baisse des français qui réduit la
consommation des ménages la baisse de
production de la filière veau grande
consommatrice de poudre de lait filière
qui produisait 405 milton en 1981 et 2
174 mille tonnes seulement aujourd'hui
les règles économiques du marché et de
la concurrence qui conduisent à la loi
de la jungle et aux importations
abusives anticommunautaire le
comportement de prédateur de la grande
distribution qui réalise des marges
exagéré via ses centrales d'achat envers
les transformateurs et enfin les
transformateurs qui sous la pression de
la grande distribution camouflent leur
marge et sont contraints de répercuter
les pressions des gms sur les
producteurs
la réduction des soutiens par l'europe
aux produits de dégagement que peuvent
être le beurre et la poudre de lait en
période de crise
le poids de l'europe libérale qui en
accord avec l'om c'est supprime
progressivement tous les outils de
régulation dont les quotas laitiers et
libéralisa outrance de marché laitier
pour que le prix de référence mondiale
soit la règle générale alors que ce prix
ne correspond qu'à 6 % des échanges
monsieur le ministre luc chatel a tenté
la semaine passée au sein de la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat
le justifier la lme et de minimiser son
rôle dans la crise laitière
pourtant cette loi censée améliorer les
relations commerciales a pour effet d
aggraver en livrant les producteurs et
transformateurs aux diktats des
centrales d'achat qui font la pluie pour
les fournisseurs et le beau temps pour
elle même pas surprenant quand on sait
que de multiples volets de la loi ont
été concoctées entre michel edouard
leclerc et le président sarkozy il y a
un an avec michel barnier
votre gouvernement a cédé une fois de
plus aux sirènes libérale de bruxelles
est retirée au cne elle le droit de
formuler des recommandations trimestriel
sur le prix du lait aujourd'hui vous
nous proposez trois outils qui sans
procès d'intention restent inefficaces
face aux problèmes de fond de la crise
nous proposait d'autoriser
l'interprofession à établir les indices
de prix il faut tout de même savoir que
les centre d'économie rurale ont déjà
tous les chiffres concernant le prix de
revient
vous nous proposez également de
multiplier les contrôles par la dgccrf
après avoir affaibli cet organisme au
nom de la rgpp où nous proposer enfin de
changer le braquet 2
servat thouars des marges et des prix
les constats et les contrôles n'ont
jamais constitué un outil efficace de
prix rémunérateurs
ils peuvent à tout le moins donner des
indications souvent déjà connu pendant
des années les producteurs en crise se
sont laissés endormir par les
instruments classiques de régulation
autorisé en europe ce qui à chaque crise
n'empêchait pas la concentration mais
rendait un peu moins douloureuse la
situation des dégagé d'office la
situation appelle autre chose que des
mesurettes ou de l'enfumage monsieur le
ministre c'est une question de jours
pour certaines exploitations de semaine
et de mois pour les autres
l'exemple calculé par le centre
d'économie rurale des côtes d'armor est
éloquent pour prendre la mesure de la
gravité de la crise
le site une exploitation laitière
dégager ces dernières années une moyenne
de 15 à 16 milles euros de revenus par
an et par unité de travail humain si
nous prenons le cas d'un exploitant
travaillant seul pour produire un quota
annuel de 200 militants nous arrivons à
1250 euros de revenus nets par mois
si on applique à cet éleveur une baisse
de 4 centimes par litre dès le quatrième
trimestre 2008
son revenu net tombe mensuel tombe à 666
euros
si nous effectuons un même calcul pour
un couple qui produit 400 mille litres
de lait par an nous arrivons même
résultat 1332 euros nets par mois pour 2
personnes au travail
à supposer que la demande des
industriels d'une baisse minimum de 100
euros pour mille litres de lait soit
appliqué dès le mois de janvier
le revenu moyen mensuel calculé à partir
des chiffres fournis par l'étude du cer
des côtes d'armor devient négatif
un éleveur qui produit 200 mille litres
de lait par an père 416 euros par mois
un couple à 400000 le quota annuel père
832 euros par mois les communistes
proposent de longue date encadrer les
marges abusives de développer la notion
de prix minimum garanti et de l'élargir
à l'europe d'utiliser le principe du
coefficient multiplicateur qui établit
un lien vertus entre le prix de vente à
la production et celui à la consommation
d'imaginer un partage équitable des
marges permettant aux producteurs de
vivre du fruit de son travail sans
pénaliser le consommateur
chaque fois nos propositions sont
caricaturés au nom de l'économie
administrée ou de la soviétisation de
l'économie je constate aujourd'hui
que la fnsea demande je cite la mise en
oeuvre d'un dispositif particulier
d'encadrement des marges et ou de
coefficient multiplicateur pour les
produits alimentaires de base
qu'il s'agisse de produits agricoles
bruts ou de première transformation
monsieur le métayer serait-il devenu
communiste connelly monsieur le ministre
mais le bon sens et la pression des
campagnes en feu le conduisent à
infléchir les règles intangibles du
libéralisme la contractualisation permet
de fixer des prix plancher dans le cadre
actuel de la loi lme
mais cela ne suffira pas monsieur le
ministre il faut réviser cette loi en
faveur des producteurs assurer la
pérennité des transformateurs et
encadrer rigoureusement la grande
distribution qui assure plus de 75% de
la mise en marché ne nous refaites pas
le coup du coefficient multiplicateur
pour les fruits et légumes voté au sénat
puis rendu inapplicable par de multiples
disposition via les décrets et autres
dispositions gouvernementales
ne laissez pas la grande distribution
répercuter ailleurs ou autrement
les pertes de marche qu'elle pourrait
subir comme elle l'a fait à chaque
nouvelle loi économique dans la temps de
légiférer efficacement il est urgent de
tenir une nouvelle table ronde pour le
second semestre 2009 qui permettent
d'assurer la poursuite de l'ensemble des
exploitations laitières et celle des
transformateurs à ce propos la situation
difficile d'entremont alliance dans
l'ouest laisse présager les pires
scénarii si le gouvernement n'agit pas
en accordant prioritairement son aide
aux producteurs dont le lait est payé en
fonction des débouchés beurre poudre en
mettant en place une péréquation
nationale est un outil de gestion
collective des volumes excédentaires
demain dans l'ouest nous craignons de
voir des producteurs abandonnés par
leurs laiteries parce que trop petit ou
trop éloignés
demain nous craignons que les outils de
transformation soit racheté par la
grande distribution ce qui accentuerait
encore la dépendance des producteurs
déjà bien affaiblie vous voyez madame et
monsieur madame lemieux mini ce pardon
tous deux vous êtes confrontés à des
responsabilités importantes pour
l'agriculture et le commerce
votre mission sera déterminant si nous
voulons conserver une agriculture
française et européenne face à la
mondialisation des échanges et aux
critères ultralibéraux qui la guide
journée
dans la suite du débat la parole et à
jean bizet pour le groupe ump pour dix
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme
beaucoup de nos collègues présents
aujourd'hui je vis au quotidien à la
crise du secteur laitier
je vois la colère et les attentes des
éleveurs mais en dépit de la résonance
locale de cette crise il me semble qu'il
nous faut aussi résonné au niveau
européen car la crise est précisément
européenne c'est d'ailleurs la mission
que m'a confiée récemment notre
commission des affaires européennes et
ce tour d'europe me semble instructif
pour comprendre nos similitudes et nos
différences dans les débats actuels et
surtout à venir autour de la pac
il faut s'inscrire dans une stratégie
d'alliance et commencer par écouter les
autres
votre nomination à ce poste monsieur le
ministre est une preuve parfaite de ces
ponts entre l'agriculture et les
affaires européennes rapport qui sort
aujourd'hui et mes collègues comme vous
même monsieur le ministre vous pourrez
en prendre connaissance si vous le
souhaitez ce tour d'europe que j'ai
menée par internet me conduit à quelques
observations
tout d'abord tous les états acceptent
les nouvelles règles du jeu du marché
même si la révolution du secteur n'a
qu'à peine dix ans le régime de prix
indicatif est totalement oubliée
enterrait il n'y a plus que le marché et
son produit inconnu du consommateur mais
essentielle pour l'industrie à savoir la
poudre de lait qui détermine aujourd'hui
une sorte de prix directeur tous les
états sont également très attaché à la
liberté contractuelle entre producteurs
et acheteurs
d'ailleurs dans plusieurs pays les
acheteurs sont des coopératives codétenu
par les éleveurs ce qui facilite ces
ponts le poids de l'industrie de
l'information dans les achats de lait
est une spécificité française
tous les états ont connu des variations
de prix considérables jeudi variations
et non pas baisse car l'année 2007 2008
avait été marquée par une flambée des
prix
la période 2008 2009 et frappée par une
baisse aussi brutale inutile de passer
en revue les situations particulières
des états mais je retiendrai s'offrent
seulement le cas des nouveaux états
membres
dont la situation est très préoccupante
ils ont moins profité de la hausse et
ont plus souffert de la baisse que les
autres états de l'union
cela crée une sorte d'amertume sinon de
rancoeur dont il faut être conscient
votre expérience européenne monsieur
mise permet de bien mesurer ces écarts
et cette sensibilité alors qu'elles le
sont pour notre crise française
il y a deux problèmes à régler les
revenus des éleveurs et les variations
de prix je commencerai par avec lui est
une piste cher aux éleveurs français
pourtant bien mal engagée je veux bien
entendu parler des quotas laitiers
la crise at-elle changé la position nos
partenaires sur ce sujet la réponse est
clairement non à aucun moment les états
ne change d'avis sur ce sujet pour deux
raisons très simples
tout d'abord tous les analystes
considèrent que la crise actuelle est
liée à l'insuffisance de la demande et
non à un excès de l'offre l'augmentation
des quotas ne change rien la preuve en
est que beaucoup de pays n'ont pas
atteint leurs quotas
il pouvait produire pouvait produire
plus elles ne l'ont pas fait ce qui
concerne la frange permets de vous
rappeler que la france étant sous
réalisation pour cette année de près
d'un milliard de litres
et donc c'est bien une preuve je dirais
d'une une crise liée à la demande et non
une crise liée à l'offre la production
s'est adapté parfois avec lenteur ou
avec retard mais l'ajustement se perd on
annonce déjà que la collecte de lait à
l'automne sera l'une des plus faibles
des dix dernières années
ensuite plusieurs pays ont intérêt à
l'augmentation des quotas soient tout
simplement pour valoriser leur potentiel
qui semble entraver parce qu'il
considère comme un carcan réglementaire
soit pour éviter une baisse brutale des
prix avant l'abandon des quotas
considéré comme acquis sur ce sujet nous
avions un allié de poids l'allemagne et
vous connaissez bien monsieur le
ministre mais il faut se rendre à
l'évidence c'était plutôt un allié de
circonstance que j'analyse précisément
dans ce rapport
l'allemagne accepte de la fin des quotas
l'abandon des quotas était décidée en
2005 est programmé en 2008
d'ailleurs il n'est pas dans l'habitude
allemande de remettre en cause les
décisions collectives du conseil
européen la france me paraît plutôt
isolé sur ce point même d'être plus
grands alliés sur la pac
l'irlande ne nous suit pas sur les
quotas dans la stratégie d'alliance que
j'appelle de mes voeux je pense qu'il
faut choisir d'autres combats face à la
volatilité des prix je crois à la
nécessité de maintenir une politique
publique
assis sur des instruments de régulation
il y en a d'autres
certes il ya des réticences de quelques
pays mais l'instabilité a été excessive
et je crois qu'une majorité est possible
sur ce concept concept de régulation
si on veut bien lui apporter quelques
ajustements à bruxelles
l'intervention est toujours actionné à
contrecoeur car elle évoque encore les
montagnes de beurre dont on nous renvoie
sans cesse l'image cette situation est
révolu le concept doit être renouvelé
l'intervention doit être moins conçu
comme un moyen de réduire des excédents
des excédents comme que comme un moyen
de lisser les évolutions de prix
les variations sont considérables le
stockage régulateur est un moyen simple
facile à mettre en oeuvre et à gérer et
qui correspond parfaitement à cette
situation je profite de l'occasion pour
le dire parce que ça a été souvent
caricaturé le bilan de santé de la pac
n'a pas supprimé
loin s'en faut les outils de régulation
que ce soit l'intervention voire même
les restitutions et dieu sait si on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la restitution ne sont
plus au mc entre guillemets compatibles
mais l'intervention n'a pas eu je dirais
la la pertinence et la signature
politique parce que tout simplement elle
est à mon avis encore sous dimensionné
les dpu pourrait aussi être modifiés les
dpu indispensable pour assurer des
revenus aux éleveurs en temps de crise
ne serait ce que pour respecter les
objectifs de traité de rome sont ils
dispensable lorsqu'elle écrit les tripes
les prix flambent
il y aura là précisément une réflexion à
mener peut être imaginé précisément des
dpu modulable variable en fonction
précisément des crises notamment dans le
crise laitière
je crois enfin que la politique agricole
commune doit être mieux évaluer on
évalue toutes les politiques européennes
tout sauf la pac l'élevage en
particulier ne peut être évaluée avec
les seuls critères de prix et de coûts
il y à là d'autres critères à prendre en
compte comme celui de la biodiversité
par exemple les politiques publiques
peuvent concerner tous les états membres
mais cela ne doit pas nous exonérer
d'une réflexion sur notre propre
organisation
la contractualisation est une piste
certes feu mais d'embûches et de pièges
que j'évoque dans mon rapport
mais sans doute utile et nécessaire
voire j'insisterai peut-être aujourd'hui
incontournable à condition qu'elle doit
être qu'elle soit pratique pertinemment
plus te ment encadrer les éleveurs ont
besoin d'une visibilité
cette visibilité est assurée au moins en
partie par les quotas décidés par la
puissance publique mais vécue comme une
sorte de contrat moral avec la fin
annoncée des quotas
il faut d'autres formes de régulation
est passé de 7 fort de cette sorte de
contrat moral public à des contrats
privés professionnels et régionaux des
contrats qui associerait la distribution
éventuellement au coeur de la bataille
des prix qu'elle le veuille ou non
j'apporte quelques précisions utiles
également pour éviter d'être trop
manichéen en faisant la distinction par
exemple entre les et produits laitiers
mais il ya aujourd'hui trop de non dits
qui laisse une détestable impression
quelques correctifs à la loi lme
pourraient s'avérer utiles
j'évoque aussi quelques pistes nationale
quels sont les moyens du ministère
acceptable sur le plan communautaire
pour accompagner la restructuration des
élevages pour développer des formules de
commercialisation nouvelle pour
favoriser le concept également de
proximité ça marche ici ou là dans
quelques régions françaises
en conclusion je crois pouvoir dire que
la crise est générale
les réactions sont diverses pour
beaucoup de pays la crise est un mauvais
moment en attendant le rebond une forme
de passage qui permet de faire émerger
les plus compétitifs dans d'autres pays
la colère est vive mais il y à une unité
la profession ne peut vivre dans un
chaos permanent
les éleveurs ont besoin de visibilité
d'être remis en confiance
chacun doit jouer son rôle en france et
en europe et le gouvernement doit
assurer le sien nous avons confiance en
vous monsieur le ministre et nous
attendons des résultats
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
de majuscule du débat la parole est à
françois fortassin pour le groupe rdse
pour six minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord monsieur le ministre je voudrais
vous souhaiter le meilleur accueil dans
notre ensemble et vous arrivez avec une
flatteuse réputation d'une personne
rompu aux questions européennes
cela vous fera certainement utile dans
ses nouvelles fonctions
mais au delà bien entendu des propos
convenus
je souhaite évoquer cette dramatique
crise laitière qui affecte notre pays
les campagnes sont en ébullition et la
colère est très grande et bien entendu
notre rôle de parlementaire
c'est de traduire cette colère car on
est dans une situation qui est
inacceptable
scandaleuse par bien des points
amoral et suicidaire près de cent mille
exploitations agricoles sont aujourd'hui
touchés plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'emplois directs ou indirects
cela est il totalement inacceptable et
scandaleux car les producteurs ne
peuvent pas être en permanence la
variable d'ajustement c'est ta morale
car comment peut-on considérer que
au même moment où les agriculteurs
producteurs de lait n'arrive pas à vivre
de leur travail
400 80 % des 400 plus grosses fortunes
françaises se trouvent dans la grande
distribution et ses fortunes ont été
réalisées non pas sur plusieurs
générations
comme c'est le cas des grandes
industries au 19ème au début du 20e
siècle mais simplement en quelques
années
ensuite il est scandaleux et immoral que
l'on fasse payer aux producteurs et aux
industriels des marchandises qu'ils
doivent livrer et qui ne sont pas payés
ce qu'on achète par exemple 500 milles
pot de yaourt mais on demande le livret
552 mid un grand coteau hebdomadaire à
parler de racket
moi je parle de gangstérisme légal et il
faut pas avoir peur des mots
il faut créer dans ce pays une véritable
solidarité de la filière
la filière est de constituer des
producteurs
elle est constituée des transformateurs
elle est constituée de la distribution
un vieil adage disant que le soleil se
lève pour tout le monde
eh bien il faut que chacun puisse vivre
décemment de son travail et nous
attendons monsieur le ministre que vous
agissez dans ce domaine sinon on
arrivera à une situation suicidaire
l'élevage laitier
avec contraintes importantes compte
exposer mes collègues en particulier la
traite deux fois par jour un élevage
laitier demande d'au moins dix ou douze
ans avant d'être constituée de façon
très valable il y a aussi des
investissements très lourds et il faut
savoir que lorsque ces éleveurs laitiers
auront abandonné
on ne reviendra pas en arrière ils ne
reprendront pas cette activité et à ce
moment là c'est de notre responsabilité
aussi de la vôtre monsieur le ministre
de faire savoir que on peut avoir une
pénurie de lait au bout de quatre ou
cinq ans si nous ne prenons pas des
mesures extrêmement draconiennes alors
c'est vrai que le problème il est
européen
mais il est aussi français
la loi lme est totalement bafouée il
faut la faire respecter
il faut créer les conditions pour qu'il
y ait une véritable solidarité de
l'ensemble de la production
aujourd'hui les producteurs le sentiment
d'être abandonnée en rase campagne et
les autres partenaires de la filière
c'est le sauve qui peut c'est pas de ma
faute c'est la faute de l'autre c'est la
faute de l'europe
ce discours est inacceptable alors nous
attendons monsieur le ministre que la
politique reprenne ses droits
d'une façon forte j'approuve la
déclaration de monsieur le président de
la république que nous avons écouté
attentivement lundi lorsqu'il a dit
l'économie doit être au service de
l'homme et non le contraire
on a là la possibilité avec cette crise
laitière de mettre en pratique
cette déclaration forte quelles que
soient nos sensibilités
nous ne pouvons que la partager aussi je
vous demande monsieur le ministre de
tout faire pour créer en dehors bien
entendu de l'action qu'on pourrait mener
sur le plan européen
je ne veux pas mes collègues l'ont
évoquée par les deux des causes du prix
du lait très élevé en 2007 2008 un
effondrement en 2009 mais de créer les
conditions de cette solidarité et aime
poser le double étiquetage pas
d'ailleurs sur les produits laitiers
vous êtes ministre alimentation et bien
je crois que c'est un élément qui est
qui me paraît être d'une importance
capitale
c'est là on peut dans ce pays
exiger la transparence et après tout
demandé l'un des consommateurs pour
faire en sorte que certaines pratiques
qui ne doivent pas avoir lieu dans notre
pays
c'est ce le plus rapidement possible
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues de m'avoir écouté
merci chers collègues le supplément la
parole et yannick botrel bronze
socialiste pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
depuis plusieurs semaines désormais
l'économie agricole à travers la
production laitière serait débat dans
notre pays
la situation des producteurs nous
interpelle par les conséquences qui se
dessine de plus en plus nettement
consécutive à l'effondrement du prix du
lait qui leur est payé le constat des
causes peut être dressé aisément et
souffre d'ailleurs assez peu de
controverse
à quoi tiennent ses causes à quelles
orientations stratégiques à quelles
décisions politiques
elles tiennent à la volonté clairement
affichée est mise en application de
considérer cette activité économique
identique aux autres c'est à dire de la
soumettre aux règles et à la loi sans
limites d'un marché libérale ce faisant
on fait abstraction d'une réalité la
production laitière par nature est liée
à des cycles de production long comme
les investissements qu'elle nécessite
elle ne peut donc s'adapter
instantanément à une conjoncture
économique variable ou volatile et ceci
d'autant moins qu'elle ne maîtrise que
partiellement ses coûts de production
que ce soit les coûts des mises aux
normes le prix des matières premières de
l'énergie nombre de charges ne sont pas
compressibles
la production laitière est par ailleurs
un facteur déterminant de la vie
économique et de l'activité de bien des
régions
elle constitue par là un élément
déterminant de l'aménagement des
territoires
raison supplémentaire pour qu'elle soit
organisée et régulé or les décisions
arrêtées depuis plusieurs années en
europe au terme de négociations entre
les gouvernements vont dans un sens
absolument opposé réduction des outils
de régulation abandon programmée des
quotas laitiers montre bien quelles
orientations ont été choisis à cet égard
se référer au marché mondial pour la
détermination des prix alors qu'il ne
concerne que 5 % de la production
globale des produits laitiers est une
aberration c'est pourtant aujourd'hui la
référence prise en compte celle qui
permet de tirer les prix vers le bas
peut-on dès lors attendre du marché qui
se corrige
de lui-même par sa propre vertu on peut
légitimement en douter
sans la volonté du politique de remettre
l'action publique au coeur du débat des
orientations et des décisions
nécessaires il est douteux qu'une
solution durable puisse émerger la
situation actuelle exige donc le retour
d'un projet d'une vision européenne de
l'agriculture de l'implication forte de
la france dans la recherche des
solutions collectives comme il a été dit
dans le contexte d'une autre crise
l'europe doit retrouver sa fonction
protectrice
là se trouve le premier objectif il faut
donner à l'échelle de l'europe un coup
d'arrêt aux orientations appliquée par
la commission et madame fischer bol le
démantèlement des quotas laitiers qui
ont depuis de nombreuses années démontré
leur utilité et leur justification doit
être stoppée il faut même leur rendre
toute leur portée à court terme en tant
qu instrument indispensable de la
maîtrise de la production et à moyen
terme en tant que condition de la survie
financière d'une majorité de producteurs
nous savons bien la chute des prix n'est
pas proportionnelle à l'ampleur de la
surproduction elles mêmes
disproportionné par rapport à celle ci
dès lors que l' équilibre de la
production du marché est rompu l'europe
doit donc s'engager dans une gestion des
volumes
il ya urgence à les réduire et à les
compenser dans un contexte de
surproduction
quant à la france en ayant adopté la lme
elle ajoute à cette situation déjà
difficile
une incroyable asymétrie dans le rapport
entre production et distribution au
détriment de la première bien entendu ce
qui est même dénoncé parfois par des
parlementaires de la majorité
enfin au plus près de nous les
producteurs sont dans une situation
d'ores et déjà préoccupante les études
produit en bretagne par les centre
d'économie rurale montre que l'
équilibre de gestion moyen des
exploitations se situe aux alentours
d'un prix de 305 euros pour mille litres
de lait payé aux agriculteurs
or aujourd'hui nous en sommes loin très
loin même dans certaines laiteries
interrogés à ce sujet les producteurs
livrant à l'entreprise entremont
alliance cité par notre collègue le
calme tout à leur quatrième entreprises
françaises du secteur 2 milliards 300
millions de litres collectés 6000
livreur en bretagne
avec un prix payé actuellement de 205
euros la situation de ces derniers est
intenable
à ce compte là crise va éliminer d'abord
les plus fragiles c'est à dire bien
souvent les investisseurs récents
autrement dit les plus jeunes lorsqu'on
sait qu'actuellement près de la moitié
des 4300 producteurs des côtes d'armor
troisième département pour la production
laitière en plus de 50 ans on mesure
mieux de quelques hypothèques engage
l'avenir
il est donc urgent qu après avoir
tergiversé le gouvernement se saisisse
enfin de la situation il est à craindre
sinon qu'à très court terme
nombre d'entre les producteurs soit
acculé à la cessation dans les pires
conditions et par conséquence que
l'économie agricole dans toutes ses
composantes soient touchés il est vital
d'intervenir dès maintenant comme il
l'est aussi de réfléchir à l'avenir de
la filière dans sa globalité sur toutes
ces questions la parole et les actes du
gouvernement sont attendus dans
l'urgence monsieur le ministre
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite du
débat la parole et à jacques muller pour
cinq minutes
quel temps
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues la crise qui
secoue depuis plusieurs semaines nos
campagnes est profonde elle vient
légitimement se manifester jusqu'au
coeur de nos villes elle résulte
essentiellement de la conjonction de
deux phénomènes le premier
l'augmentation des quotas laitiers qui
préfigure leur disparition programmée
par la commission européenne
cette dérégulation de la production
laitière résulte essentiellement d'une
approche néo libérale des marchés
agricoles cher à madame fischer boel
chacun sait pourtant que les marchés
agricoles sont particulièrement
volatiles en raison d'une inhalaient il
n'y as this it et de la demande par
rapport au prix les augmentations de
production des cages excède la demande
font mécaniquement plonger les prix à
moins de disposer de moyens adaptés de
transformation et de stockage qui ont un
coût et par conséquent aussi des limites
telle est la raison qui avait conduit à
instaurer les quotas laitiers en 1983 la
commission joue avec le feu en ouvrant
la voie pour des raisons idéologiques à
la suppression de ces quotas et en
tablant sur la demande mondiale pour
absorber les excédents de lait en poudre
et de beurre
c'est un pari aussi hasardeuse que
détestable sur le fond hasardeuse parce
que la demande mondiale n'est pas un
débouché stable après l'embellie de 2007
qui a fait illusion
le marché s'est effondré en 2008 mettait
en difficulté les transformateurs
d'excédent laitiers détestable parce que
contraires aux principes essentiels de
souveraineté alimentaire
déjà évoquée dans notre débat sur l' omc
quand donc les pays industrialisés dont
l'europe cesseront ils de déverser leurs
excédents agricoles sur les pays en
développement avec pour conséquence le
blocage structurel dramatique du
développement de l'agriculture vivrière
le deuxième c'est no men est le problème
de la représentation du monde agricole
au sein des instances
interprofessionnelles caractérisée par
ce qu'il faut appeler le monopole du
syndicat majoritaire alors qu'il ne
fédère que la moitié des producteurs
laitiers
le compromis qu'il négocie avec les
firmes agroalimentaires du secteur
laitier en termes de répercussions de la
crise du marché mondial sur les prix
versé au producteur ne sont pas
acceptables supportable pour la grande
majorité des petits et moyens
producteurs aujourd'hui littéralement
asphyxié implicitement ces compromis
font le jeu des grands groupes privés ou
coopératif que nous connaissons tous qui
transfère la crise engendrée par la
gestion des 90 mille tonnes de lait en
poudre et les 120 mille tonnes de beurre
sur le monde agricole et qui traduise
sur le terrain les velléités inavouables
de la commission européenne engager une
nouvelle étape dans la restructuration
du secteur laitier refaire en quelque
sorte du monde salt et liquider les
petites et moyennes exploitations
laitières jugées improductives
vous l'aurez compris cette crise
fondamentalement pose la question du
modèle agricole laitiers quels types
d'exploitations laitières veux-t-on
promouvoir des usines à lait avec des
vaches à potentiel maximiser gaver
d'ensilage de maïs et de tourteaux de
soja importé produisant de manière
intensive pour le stockage et
l'exportation ou bien des exploitations
agricoles avec des vaches plus rustique
par conséquence moins traité permettant
de valoriser les airs les herbages
produisant pour un marché intérieur et
valorisant dès que possible leurs
produits sur des circuits courts une
nouvelle fois nous mesurons combien les
dimensions économique sociale et
environnementale
loin de s'opposer se conjuguent mais
encore faut-il rendre avec les fantasmes
néolibéraux selon lesquelles il faut
réintroduire à tout prix du marché dans
l'agriculture et continuer d'affaiblir
les outils de régulation
c'est pourquoi les verts demandent le
rétablissement des côtés quotas laitiers
malgré leurs inconvénients le principe
des quantums nous paraissait plus
intéressants les côtes avaient permis de
gérer dans la durée
l'évolution du secteur laitier de
prévenir les crises de surproduction
ma collègue et amie bernadette bourzai
sénatrice de corrèze se joint également
à moi pour mettre en exergue une autre
dimension des quotas les quotas
régionaux apparaissent comme le seul
moyen de répartir harmonieusement la
production laitière sur le territoire
est d'éviter que les régions de plaine
et surtout portuaire à bas coûts de
production viennent concurrencer
abusivement les régions de montagne ou
dites défavorisées dont la seule
ressource agricole et l'herbe
cette herbe doit être valorisée par nos
élevages y compris laitiers c'est un
enjeu environnemental qui à l'heure du
grenelle de l'environnement n'aura
échappé à personne mais c'est également
un enjeu sociétal en termes
d'aménagement du territoire
nous devons tout faire pour éviter le
déménagement programmé de la production
laitière engagé par l'augmentation et la
suppression des quotas
monsieur le ministre chers collègues je
vous invite à considérer cette crise
laitière comme une opportunité une
opportunité de remettre à plat la
politique agricole d'en stopper les
dérives néolibérales et de promouvoir un
modèle agricole européen en phase en
phase avec les attentes de nos
concitoyens qui se sont récemment
exprimés clairement dans ce sens un
modèle plus respectueux de
l'environnement et pourvoyeur d'emplois
car moins intensif moins dépendants
d'importations plus territorialisée un
modèle implicitement plus solidaire des
pays du sud car tourner vers une demande
intérieure
le produit de qualité je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue civile et balla
par l'état jean pierre godefroy pour le
groupe socialiste pour cinq minutes
si le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues vous permettrait un
non-spécialiste d'intervenir dans ce
débat aujourd'hui la crise de la
production laitière ne peut plus
l'espace médiatique avec autant
d'intérêt
ça risque de revenir que ces dernières
semaines cependant les problèmes
soulevés par les producteurs les
difficultés économiques qui rencontrent
l'état catastrophique catastrophique de
leur bilan financier notamment chez les
agriculteurs perdure monsieur le
ministre
les quelques mesures annoncées par votre
prédécesseur n'ont pas réglé le problème
au mieux elles m'ont fait que gagner
quelques mois d'ailleurs 1500
producteurs réunis à
saint-hilaire-du-harcouët dans le
département de la manche ont voté en
faveur d'une grève européenne du lait
qui consiste comme vous le savez à jeter
ou à donner le lait trait pour faire
pression sur l'industrie laitière et les
instances politiques afin que les prix
remontent
c'est une option de désespoir aux
conséquences très graves
je suis à lui de ce département de la
manche pour mon collègue jean bizet dont
je suis loin de partager la compétence
il ne sais bien je lui a dit en matière
laitières bien évidemment après nous
pourrons en discuter départements
producteurs de lait producteurs en
volume premier département en nombre de
producteurs lors d'une table ronde
organisée à la préfecture de région à
quand le 11 juin dernier
j'ai pu constater que les situations et
est variable d'un département à l'autre
selon que la production de lait
l'activité principale ce qui est souvent
le cas chez nous voire exclusive ou une
production complémentaire
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'il est
impossible de vivre avec des prix
pratiqués depuis le début de l'année
pour une production moyenne d'environ
300 milles dit si j'ai bien compris les
producteurs de mon département l'ont dit
clairement l'accord signé portant à 280
euros les mille litres de lait tout à
fait insuffisant notamment pour les
jeunes pros jeunes producteurs
en effet il ne leur permet pas de
couvrir le coût des investissements
nécessaires notamment en matière
environnementale ou de normes
réglementaires
ils les contrats toujours dante actuel
des choses à produire à perte
de même si dans ma région les
représentants des grandes et moyennes
surfaces présents à cette table ronde se
sont engagés à ne pas renégocier à la
baisse les prix d'achat des produits
laitiers de grande consommation jusqu'au
31 décembre 2009
cet engagement doit faire l'objet d'une
validation niveau national et c'est vous
le reconnaîtrez très largement
insuffisant comme engagement quant aux
autres mesures suggérées notamment du
côté des banques le report d'un an des
invités d'investissement en particulier
ceux de mise aux normes ou la
sollicitation du côté de l'état des
reports ou dégrèvement de charges
sociales
ce ne sont que des mesures palliatives
qui le pourront régler le problème au
fond le problème via d'abord de la reine
des réglementations niveau européen j'ai
bien entendu propos de mon collègue jean
bizet tout à l'heure concernant
l'augmentation des quotas et la
suppression 2015 et son analyse
je crois cependant que cela quand même
contribué à déstabiliser la rémunération
de la production et si en france
monsieur le ministre la situation est si
grave c'est parce que s'ajoute à cette
déréglementation au niveau européen la
fameuse loi elle est peu loi de
modernisation de l'économie rend dans la
négociation libre non encadrés ce qui
devait soi-disant permettre au marché de
s'autoréguler ça devait être d'ailleurs
favorable au consommateur
il s'avère que c'est une erreur fatale
tant pour les producteurs que pour les
consommateurs qui n'ont pas perçu de
baisse sur les prix au passage personne
ne peut croire que la mise en place d'un
observatoire des prix et des marges
suffira à remédier à cette situation
à qui cela profite-t-il en posant la
question j'y réponds et mes autres
collègues forte à sahili a largement
répondu avec la verve qu'on lui connaît
tout à l'heure une plus grande
transparence est nécessaire pour évaluer
les marges différents acteurs de la
chaîne
surtout quand on sait que le prix du
lait payé par le consommateur a augmenté
de 17% entre l'été 2007 et à l'été 2008
elle n'a baissé que de 2 % depuis l'été
2008 aujourd'hui les producteurs
attendent donc des actes forts
ils sont dans une situation sociale
intonow c'est leur avenir
c'est l'avenir de leur famille c'est
l'avenir de nos exploitations qui sont
en jeu monsieur le ministre nous
attendons les propositions susceptibles
d'apporter une réponse à la détresse des
producteurs et de remettre de l'ordre
dans la filière notamment en révisant la
loi lme dont nous avions à l'époque
longuement expliqué les dérives qu'elle
risquait de produire en spécifiant bien
que la politique européenne ne peut pas
rester figé en la matière les
producteurs de foie compter sur un prix
de vente de leur production garantie la
juste rémunération de leur travail ainsi
que sur des volumes régulés par une plus
grande maîtrise de la production
monsieur le ministre c'est un message
que je tenais ou transmettent en tant
que membre de la commission des affaires
sociales car j'ai bien compris dans
cette réunion à caen ou mois de juin que
les producteurs étaient dans une très
grande prêtresse et après les avoir
entendues j'estime est tout à fait
normal de vous interroger à cet égard
merci non chaque lundi dernier encore
inscrire nos débats la parole est au
président adrien gouteyron que le groupe
ump
merci de vos encouragements
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais très certainement même et
sioniste
comment pas saisir l'occasion de ce
débat pour ne pas rappeler pour rappeler
part donc dans un département comme le
mien la haute-loire la production
laitière occupe une place prépondérante
dans l'économie agricole 2400
producteurs soit à peu près le deux
tiers des exploitations
comment ne pas relever ensuite qu'après
les manifestations dont tout le monde
s'en doute a parlé l'accord du 4 juin a
été accueillie avec une certaine disons
résignation et le sentiment aigu que le
problème de fond existe toujours et je
prends un exemple d'ailleurs je vous
demande de pardonner ce que peut avoir
de factuel mon propos
il y a eu le 23 juin c'est mardi dernier
une réunion de l'interprofession
régionale auvergne limousin et les
tensions entre producteurs et
transformateurs ont été ville n'ont pas
trouvé d'accord
la discussion reste ouverte et c'est
bien le signe que le malaise perdure
persiste rendre hommage notre
prédécesseur michel dernies barnier qui
a su dans l'urgence organisé réunir tout
le monde autour de la table les trois
partenaires de la filière et apporter
quelques mesures susceptibles d'alléger
les charges de des producteurs de
certains d'entre eux et de pallier
quelques difficultés mais je crains en
regardant mon département monsieur le
ministre que les exploitations qui
risque d'être frappée ne soit 1 soit les
exclus ou les exploitations les plus
performantes
celles qui ont un sens investi assume
donc des charges de remboursement
d'emprunt très lourde
et puis à l'autre bout de la chaîne les
plus petites celles dans le volume de
production ne permet pas de faire face
aux difficultés conjoncturelles actuelle
il ya donc là vraiment un une situation
grave pour l'économie laitière
donc pour l'économie de notre pays et je
crois que nous ne pouvons pas simplement
laisser faire mais je sais que ce n'est
pas votre attention
j'ai lu dans le compte-rendu dans le
bulletin de vote qui rend compte des
débats des commissions
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques
les propos de luc chatel ministre qui
était à l'époque le secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'industrie et de la
consommation il a rappelé que l'ancien
système de régulation du prix du lait
fondé sur une recommandation du cnj anne
était insuffisant qu'il ne respectait
pas les règles de la concurrence c'est
qu'au demeurant il n'était pas efficace
et il a donc indiqué les mesures qui ont
été prises la création d'une brigade de
contrôle une grande enquête sur les prix
des produits laitiers pour accélérer les
travaux de l'observatoire des prix et
des marges dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure
moi aussi je regarde cela monsieur le
ministre avec un certain scepticisme
mais il faut voir comment ça fonctionne
il est certain qu'on a besoin dans ce
domaine là de plus de clarté depuis de
cartes et en particulier sur la
répartition de la valeur ajoutée
je ne veux pas luc chatel dans son
intervention intéressante à la
commission des affaires économiques
avait indiqué avec beaucoup de fermeté
que la répartition de cette valeur
ajoutée était pas satisfaisante
déséquilibré je crois monsieur le
ministre que ce compte à ce constat
pardon nous invite à l'action qui ne
voient ce déséquilibré qui ne voit aussi
que le déséquilibre des forces en
présence entre les on le sait des cinq
grandes centrales et les centaines de et
les s'entraîne deux transformateurs il
ya évidemment une situation profondément
structurellement disons disons le
déséquilibré
je voudrais dire un mot de l'importance
dans la plupart des cas des marges
arrière monsieur le ministre je vais le
faire non pas d'une manière générale
mais en prenant un exemple et je vous
assure que c'est un exemple adhérer il
s'agit d'une petite entreprise une
coopérative d'ailleurs qui n'est pas de
mon département
mémé schisme ont été données par
quelqu'un qui participait conseil
d'administration 20 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires
marche arrière 2 millions d'euros dé %
du chiffre d'affaires c'est pas normal
ça n'est pas supportable
monsieur le ministre je sais bien que
les situations sont les imagine que les
situations sont inégales que ce n'est
pas partout la même chose mais quand
même
il ya bien là un problème et il ya une
conséquence évidemment extrêmement
sérieuse du point de vue de la
lisibilité du processus économique
or on a besoin en ce domaine là vous le
savez bien monsieur le ministre de
visibilité je voudrais profiter de ce
propos du ministre pour vous signaler la
situation d'une entreprise de mon
département cette fois ci il s'agit de
l'entreprise via lacta au puy-en-velay
c'est une entreprise qui n'est pas
considérable mais qui économise
économiquement compte énormément dans le
bassin du puy 180 salariés environ 150
producteurs et les tendres en difficulté
il y à un projet de reprise
à mon avis il affaire n'est pas fille
d'après ce que je sais la sphère n'est
pas n'est pas encore aboutie il y a
encore beaucoup de conditions à remplir
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
intéresser à ce dossier je sais bien que
vous avez beaucoup de dossiers sur votre
table mais puis-je vous demander de
regarder cette affaire parce que si ce
projet de reprise n'aboutissaient pas ce
serai et je pèse mes mots tout à fait
catastrophique pour le bassin du puy
je vais terminer mon propos en disant un
petit mot de la surproduction dont on a
l'habitude de parler et c'est mon
collègue gens disaient qu'ils me le
rappelait tout à l'heure sur le banc en
me donnant des points qui se développe
dans son rapport il rappelle jean bizet
monsieur le ministre que la france n'est
pas en surproduction qu'elle n'a pas
réalisé la totalité de son quota -5%
donc le problème ce n'est pas celui de
la surproduction
c'est essentiellement celui de la
demande est évidemment que évidemment ce
problème est aggravé par la crise et
jean vient tout naturellement à ma
conclusion de sucre ministre en vous
disant que nous attendons beaucoup de
boue tout simplement vous avez au niveau
européen
prix totalement votre place vous avez la
capacité d'agir
monsieur le ministre il faut que
l'europe joue pleinement son rôle de
régulation
ça va être une de vos tâches je suis
persuadé que vous aurez à coeur de la
mener à bien
nous comptons sur vous et nous avons
confiance en merci à leur collègue
la parade est un chef bruno le maire
ministre de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture et de la pêche
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs devraient
commencer cette intervention par trois
remarques en allant du plus générale au
plus particulier première remarque très
générale pour répondre aux sénateurs
müller est précise et la vision de long
terme que je me fais de la filière
laitière et la production de l'aide
entre pays pour lui dire très clairement
que ma vision n'est pas celle d'une
production de lait intensive dans des
termes dans lesquels on entasse ray des
milliers de bêtes pour produire un lait
qui ne correspondrait pas à notre
exigence de sécurité sanitaire
ma vision est bien davantage celle de la
promotion de produits de qualité
soucieuse de la sécurité sanitaire et
respectueuse de l'identité de nos
territoires
on ne va pas laisser disparaître les
établissements laitiers les productions
laitières de notre territoire au motif
qu'il serait trop petit ou
paradoxalement de trop grande qualité
parce que c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit
deuxième remarque comment est ce que je
vois cette crise laitière et la
possibilité d'en sortir
je crois qu'elle deux choses très
différentes sur lesquels il faut que
nous travaillons qui sont
complémentaires
la première chose c'est d'arriver dans
le prolongement des mesures qui ont déjà
été annoncés par michel barnier sur
lesquelles je reviendrai et de l'accord
interprofessionnel qui a été conclue
d'arriver à résoudre à l'échelle
nationale la crise
dans l'immédiat essayez de regarder je
verrai demain des producteurs laitiers
dans ma région
nous regarderons ce qui peut être
amélioré
l'autre direction allait très clair
c'est d'offrir une perspective de long
terme et une prévisibilité aux
producteurs laitiers aucun responsable
d'activités commerciales ne pourrait
arriver à survivre avec des prix qui
varient de
2 % à chaque saison parce que il n'ya
aucune prédit visibilité de long terme
sur le prix de la production c'est
impossible
donc il faut que nous donnions de la
prévisibilité il faut qu'une d'oignons
de la stabilité
et cela passe à la fois par des
décisions nationales c'est la
contractualisation sur laquelle j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir et puis par des
décisions évidemment communautaire enfin
dernière troisième remarque
l'introduction très précises pour
répondre adrien gouteyron et est la
question qui m'a été posée
oui je suivrai le dossier de via lacta
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de dossiers
qui s'accumulent sur mon bureau mais
vous connaissez mon goût pour le travail
donc je m'intéresserais à cette
entreprise d'abord parce qu'elle touche
le secteur laitier ensuite parce que
vous me l'avez demandé
et en troisième lieu parce que c'est
dans la ville de mon ami laurent
wauquiez ça fait une raison
supplémentaire pour le faire sur la
situation laitière dans son ensemble je
crois que vous avez tous dressé un
tableau très claire de la situation
jacqueline gourault a évoqué sa
participation à un kobe ce dans son
département j'étais moi-même au comice
agricole des andelys la semaine dernière
où j'ai passé tout mon samedi après midi
j'ai eu l'occasion
discutez de ce sujet et je reprends le
même mot que j'emploierais l'année
intervention il y à une détresse des
producteurs laitiers en france comme
dans le reste des pays européens il faut
donc y répondre
la réponse ça ne vous étonnera pas que
je commence par là elle tient d'abord à
l'union européenne et à la solution
communautaire et là je voudrais revenir
très précisément sur quelques points qui
ont été soulevé à juste titre par
l'ensemble d'entre eux je crois que le
bilan de santé de la pac a permis de
réintroduire un vrai pilotage économique
et politique de la production et des
marchés laitiers nous avons deux rendez
vous politique en 2010 et en 2012 pour
décider des options à retenir notamment
sur cette question je les ai dit d'en -
précédentes interventions de l'avenir
des quotas laitiers
mais là je dois dire et j'assume
pleinement cette
position je partage pleinement l'analyse
qui a été faite notamment par jean bizet
de la situation j'ai regardé
attentivement depuis mon entrée en
fonction la situation la question n'est
pas celle de l'offre
la question est celle de la demande la
question n'est pas de savoir s'il faut
maintenir des quotas laitiers
la question de savoir si nous
remplissons les quotas laitiers nous ne
remplissons pas nos quotas laitiers
je veux bien plaidé matin midi et soir à
la commission européenne et au conseil
européen pour le rétablissement de
quotas laitiers
mais je vais vous dire je n'aime pas à
livrer des batailles qui sont soit
inutile soit perdue d'avancé
j'aime livrer des batailles qui améliore
la situation concrète de nos concitoyens
si je me bats pour rétablir des quotas
laitiers qu'est ce qui va se passer
d'abord je ne suis pas sûr d'obtenir la
majorité nécessaire au conseil européen
pour le faire et ensuite si j'obtiens
ses quotas laitiers
j'ai bien peur de rétablir une ligne
maginot qui ne permettra pas de répondre
aux interrogations des producteurs
laitiers en france
alors est ce que cela veut dire qu'il ne
faut aucune régulation et qu'il faut
laisser la libre concurrence gérer le
secteur laitier
je vous redis ce que j'ai dit
précédemment ma réponse est clairement
non nous avons besoin d'une régulation
parce que la production laitière n'est
pas une production comme les autres
c'est pas une production dans laquelle
le marché systématiquement stable dans
lequel le climat est systématiquement
assuré dans lequel la production et la
demande sont systématiquement garantie
ce n'est pas le cas et donc en face de
l'instabilité caractéristique de ce
marché laitier
il faut mettre une régulation de la
production et je crois que c'est là
dessus qu'il faut qu'on se batte quel
type de régulation du secteur laitier
sera efficace pour garantir à long terme
une stabilité des cours du lait en
france et en europe et donc la
soutenabilité de l'activité économique
la production laitière en europe ses
seins je crois la vraie question plutôt
que de se focaliser sur ce débat quotas
pas quotas qui me risque à mon sens
d'être un débat théologique
plus que pratique est par ailleurs pour
engager dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
cette régulation de la production
essayer d'offrir un avenir cohérent à la
production laitière
il est indispensable de regarder quels
sont les partenaires européens sur
lesquels nous pourrons nous appuyer je
vous ai dit je me rendrai en allemagne
très vite
je crois que ça fait partie là aussi
d'une stratégie d'alliance très utile
est tout à fait nécessaire
je tiens à rappeler aussi que l'accord
que nous avons obtenu à l'échelle
européenne a permis de limiter les
effets de la crise est tellement de
façon insuffisante mais de les limiter
néanmoins les aides au stockage privé du
beurre ont été lancées dès le 1er
janvier 2009
les restitutions pour l'exportation ont
été réintroduites à la fin du mois de
janvier pour une large gamme de produits
laitiers et à partir du 1er mars les
achats l'intervention publique ont
débuté d'abord atrix comme vous le savez
puis par adjudication à des prix très
proche des prix d'intervention
ces interventions ont permis de
stabiliser la situation et les cours
aujourd'hui du beurre comme de la poudre
de lait se situe quasiment au prix
d'intervention
je ne dis pas c'est parfait je dis
simplement que ces décisions ont permis
d'améliorer la situation
néanmoins je les dis là aussi dans ma
précédente intervention des incertitudes
persistent et l'insatisfaction également
nous avons donc demandé conjointement
avec l'allemagne
au dernier conseil européen une
mobilisation plus intense des outils de
régulation des marchés la commission l'a
fait notamment sur les restitutions à
l'exportation et sur les mesures de
stockage sur les mesures efficaces les
mesures cohérentes c'est que je crois
dans le long terme pourrait être utilisé
davantage
elle devrait être prolongée au delà des
dates actuellement prévues par la
réglementation ce sera aussi l'objet de
mon entretien et qu'on afficheurs bull
tout à l'heure pour essayer de la
convaincre d'aller plus loin dans ses
mesures de façon à répondre aux
interrogations des producteurs laitiers
enfin cet accord sur le bilan de la pac
permet également à chaque état membre
vous le savez d'orienter une partie des
aides directes en fonction de choix que
sont les choix nationaux c'est une
nouveauté dont nous avons su tirer
profit
les mesures qui ont été décidées le 23
février conduit ça sert à orienter en
2010 près de 1,4 milliard d'euros soit
18% des aides directes reçues par les
agriculteurs en faveur de l'élevage à
l'herbe
une enveloppe de 45 millions d'euros
sera également consacré la production
laitière en montagne à travers une aide
couplée au litre de lait qui sera de
l'ordre de 20 euros les mille litres
voilà pour l'aspect communautaire ou
encore je veux le redire la direction
que j'entends donner à ces négociations
communautaires
elle est simple c'est la mise en place
une véritable régulation de la
production le secteur laitier qui soit
efficace sur la base d' alliance solide
avec nos partenaires européens
je vais vous dire vous avez eu la
gentillesse de me reconnaître une
expérience européenne
rien n'est pire dans le communautaire au
conseil européen à la commission que de
s'arc-bouter sur une position sans avoir
les alliances nécessaires pour les
soutenir parce que dans ce cas là vous
risquez toujours en moins de négociation
d'être contournée et à force d'avoir
tenu une position trop rigide pas
raisonnable pas tourné vers l'avenir de
céder face à des partenaires plus
nombreux et d'être obligé de revenir en
france avec un accord qui n'est pas bon
pour les français c'est précisément ce
que je m'efforcerai d'hésiter pour le
secteur agricole au niveau national le
ministre l'agriculture précédent michel
barnier avait décidé de geler la
première couche de quotas de 1%
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure une mission
de médiation a également été mise en
place conjointement avec le secrétariat
d'état chargé de l'industrie et de la
consommation
nous avons également proposer un nouveau
cadre de régulation pour le secteur
laitier
ce cadre vous le connaissez parfaitement
il repose sur le rôle central de
l'interprofession laitière tel qu'il a
été défini en décembre dernier dans la
loi
de finances pour 2009 il donne à
l'interprofession les moyens de
construire de nouvelles relations
contractuelles durables qui porteront
notamment sur la définition du prix sur
les engagements sur les volumes sur les
calendriers de livraison qui sont un
aspect qui n'a pas été soulevée mais tu
étais un aspect important aussi du
problème sur les modalités de règlement
les modalités de renégociation des
modalités de résiliation des contrats
cette question la contractualisation
elle est absolument majeur dans aucun
secteur économique
une fois encore on ne peut avancer et
progresser sans savoir comment sont
fixés les prix quand est-ce qu'ils sont
fixés
quels sont les délais de livraison quels
sont les délais de paiement le secteur
laitier est un des secteurs exceptionnel
dans lequel ces règles ne s'appliquent
pas eh bien ces règles il faut les
définir les appliquer et les faire
respecter si jamais cela n'est pas le
cas
et par rapport à ce que disait monsieur
leucan tout à l'heure la
contractualisation n'est pas un écran de
fumée
la contractualisation c'est la solution
alors bien entendu pour vérifier qu'elle
est respecté il faut vérifier qu'elle
est appliquée par tous les acteurs de la
profession et par tous les signataires
mais elle est sans doute une des voies
d'avenir les plus prometteuses par
ailleurs je note que en négociant cet
accord cela au moins permis aux
différents acteurs de l'interprofession
de rediscuter ensemble de parler est
d'aboutir à une solution qui a été signé
en présence de mon prédécesseur michel
barnier
le prix moyen qui était trouvé de 280
euros pour les bills litres c'est un
prix moyen se croient que le non dit
bien ce qu'il veut dire
mais l'accord est aujourd'hui la seule
base d'entente entre les différents
acteurs de la filière nous aurions tort
de l'affaiblir ou de vouloir le remettre
en cause sa situation de crise actuelle
c'est une base stable solide
je ne dis pas qu'elle est parfaite pour
les producteurs je sais très bien ce
qu'elle signifie un teint de revenus
pour les producteurs simplement mieux
vaut une base stable solide sur laquelle
un accord était trouvé qu'une remise en
cause radicale qui à mon sens
vrai de sérieuses difficultés vous savez
enfin que ça tombe des aides directes
ont été développés par le gouvernement
par le premier ministre directement le
pré ministre a notamment annoncé que 70%
des aides directes communautaire pour la
campagne 2009 seraient versés par
anticipation dès le 16 octobre
enfin il a décidé et là aussi je
voudrais m'arrêter à l'instant sur ce
point parce que c'est quelque chose qui
correspond à une conviction profonde
chez moi de faire une transparence
totale sur les prix et sur les marges
et pour cela de lancer une enquête
auprès des entreprises et des centrales
de grande distribution
les données qui résulteront de cette
enquête seront communiqués dans le cadre
de l'observatoire des prix et des marges
je ne reprendrai pas pour ne pas abréger
trop rapidement makaya ministériel les
propos de françois fortassin sur les
comportements des uns ou des autres je
dis simplement que la transparence
totale est une exigence républicaine
personne ne peut se satisfaire d'une
situation dans laquelle on ne sait pas
qui paye quoi qui gagne quoi qui empoche
la plus value ça n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas acceptable ni pour les
producteurs laitiers
ni pour les citoyens français dans leur
ensemble pourraient les quelques
éléments je vais porter à votre
connaissance
vous pouvez compter en tout cas sur mon
travail et ma totale détermination
vous venez de suivre un débat sur la
crise de la filière laitière pour voir
ce débat notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous avec
les travaux parlementaires cet après
midi à 15 heures avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement merci de
votre fidélité et à très bientôt sur
public sénat